Speaker 1: We have been following during our
live streams, not so much during the podcast,
but during our live streams. This trucker
convoy in Canada, which has been I don't
even really want to call it organizing. They've
sort of been demonstrating by blocking roads and
honking horns against vaccine mandates heavily
related to provincial Canadian government
decisions. And now the big thing is that. The
Canadian truckers are going to come to the U.S.
along with American truckers in order to protest
Joe Biden's vaccine mandates, and of course,
the problem with that is there really are no
such mandates. The Supreme Court blocked the
Biden mandate, so we're going to get to that.
But there are people, including Tucker Carlson,
who are now. Rand Paul is another. They are
starting to lionize these truckers as heroic
freedom fighters against Biden's oppressive, you
know, whatever. Let's take a listen to Tucker here
telling us what's going to be happening.
Speaker 2: And in that feeling tonight,
a group of American truckers announced they will
begin a nationwide truck convoy in this country
starting next month in protest
against Joe Biden's vaccine mandate.
Speaker 1: Right now, the problem is that Joe
Biden's vaccine mandates essentially do not
exist. I mean, it's, you know, it's sort of like
we must protest against the American lockdowns,
right? What you mean sometimes people wear masks.
What? What lockdowns are you talking about? The
Supreme Court blocked the Biden vaccine mandate
for employers with more than 100 employees in
January. It's done. There is no such mandate. Not
to mention that it wasn't even really a mandate
and that anybody who didn't want to be vaccinated
could just test instead and only once a week,
not once a day. The way Fox News is much
stricter requirement put in place. States
are responsible for implementing their own
vaccine requirements as they so please.
Different states have put in place
different rules and as a reminder,
the requirements for crossing the border.
You know, a big thing with truckers is, Oh,
we, you got to be vaccinated, to go to Canada or
to come back from Canada, whatever this is. No one
applying in many countries and it's applying in
both directions. So the idea of protesting Biden's
vaccine mandates is bogus and bizarre. This is not
really about vaccine mandates. First and foremost,
it's about once again similarly to the Trump riots
and Trump's threats for mass protests and all
these things. It's about generating unrest, which
they believe they can use to their advantage.
There's a few different ways in which they might
do that, which we'll talk about later this week.
The other important aspect of this American
truck convoy that is, as usual, hypocritical and
deceptive is the very same people blaming Biden
for the supply chain issues, which are really
global supply chain issues that need to be fixed,
of course, but they're blaming Biden for them.
They are going to do something which will,
at least in principle, make those supply and
supply chain issues worse. It is not the mandates
that are making the supply chain issues a problem.
There are global economic realities that are
having that impact. But taking all of these
truckers who themselves are responsible for moving
product around and not only taking them off the
road moving product, but also blocking roads and
bridges or whatever they plan to do, that's going
to make it more difficult to move products around
the United States. They're going to make worse the
very problem that they are blaming Joe Biden for.
So it doesn't have to do with vaccine mandates.
Obviously, if you couldn't tell. And also remember
the hypocrisy that they claim to be all about law
and order. And yet they are encouraging blocking
roads, which is against the law, and we can have
our views. You know, it's a completely legitimate
perspective to defend that when it is time to make
an impact. You don't protest in the ways that make
everybody comfortable part of civil disobedience.
Long history of this is what you're going to do
things that are going to make people uncomfortable
so that they pay attention to you. I get that. But
what was their view of antifa blocking roads or
Black Lives Matter blocking roads? They were all
about law and order then and now. All of a sudden,
breaking the law is justified to protest
nonexistent mandates that they claim to be
protesting against. So the real concern at the
end of the day is, is this going to lead to more
violence and more insanity in Canada? Although
there was a smattering of white nationalism,
anti-Semitism and xenophobia within these
protests. They were mostly what we would generally
describe as peaceful in the United States. I worry
that they won't be. And Donald Trump's continued
escalating rhetoric about we're going to protest
this and the biggest protests ever and all of this
kind of coded language about protests. I'm worried
about what's going to happen next month. We will
be following it. And I'm curious to hear from you.
Let me know at De Packman. What do you expect as
far as this American version of the Canadian truck
convoy is concerned? What do you? Back to see.
The David Pakman Show is viewer and listener
funded media, we depend on your support,
and you can sign up at join Packman dot com.
We do an extra show every single day called
the bonus show for our website members. We also
provide a commercial free audio and video feed
for our members, and you get access to The Daily
Show about six hours earlier than we release it
publicly. All of those great benefits and more are
available. If you sign up at join Packman dot com.